[Music]
xavier is with us in
uh orlando florida hi xavier how are you
how you doing sir good man what's up
yeah i have a question from
my wife and i you know we just started
the baby step uh
one monday um
i was reading the book when i get to to
the part where it says
that i have to have all my bills current
so my question is before before we do
the thousand dollars we have to have all
the bills current
right my question is when you're so far
behind sir
how you make how you get to be current
okay that's a really good question
thank you for calling um it's not to say
you're punished but the baby steps don't
work while you're
got all these well you got these hornets
nest of bills chasing you right
so we got to get the things calmed down
to be able to work the baby steps so i
appreciate you a lot
calling in because that's where sharon
and i found ourselves a few years back
is in that same
situation okay what are you behind on
um uh one car payment is a month
two month behind you know my light
bill's a little bit behind
the insurance a little bit behind what
else
um that's about it to be honest with you
okay how much is your car payment
um i have one is three 350
and the other one is 500 what are you
behind on the 500
actually no the the 350 yeah yeah the
the 500
yes sir okay all right and how about how
far behind on are you on the electric
what's it take to get current um
about a month maybe one month how much
is that
uh about 200 okay and what about the
insurance is this car insurance you're
behind on
yes sir how far behind are you on that
and what's it take to get a current
money wise
it's going to take maybe 300 and some
357 dollars
okay cool all right so i got 500 200
and 350. i got a thousand bucks changes
your life
okay you see i did that yes sir
what do you guys make what's your
household income um between my wife and
i we make uh 89 000 a year
okay great news right okay so here's
what we're going to do
you're going to get on the online i'm
going to give you
ramsey plus which will get you hooked up
to
the full the full thing man you put you
in
financial peace university the class
that almost 10 million people have been
through
but most importantly for this discussion
it's going to put you into every dollar
the pr with the premium version where it
hooks to your bank account
to do your budget and you and your wife
are going to sit down tonight
and you're going to work on that budget
using that every dollar app okay
oh are you yeah i'm going to give you
the whole thing free
oh my because i really appreciate that
i've been where you are i've been scared
i remember how it feels how old are you
sir i'm not scared i am freaking out to
be honest with you
that's okay how old are you i'm 42 years
old
okay cool so here's what we're going to
do
the uh what you're going to do is you're
going to each
month you need to take the money
that you have coming in and give it an
assignment
before the month begins okay
so you've got pretty substantial money
coming in
in july and maybe another check in june
correct
yes sir okay so what does your take-home
pay look like a month
i get uh my take-home pay is 1600.
a month oh no a month uh no 1600 every
every two weeks okay so 3200 for you
that means your wife's probably doing
uh two to three thousand as well right
yes sir
okay so i'm just gonna say six thousand
dollars just for an example
all right okay now what i want you to do
here's how you get current to answer
your original question
you're going to use this budget for or
this budget app tonight
to first thing you buy before you
buy anything with your six thousand
dollars for this coming month
is food before your family does anything
they gotta eat agreed
yes sir and so we're gonna put down a
budget for food
how many kids you got oh we have no kids
in the house our kids are gone and
married
okay so no eating out you're broke and a
thousand dollars behind
you don't need to go to a freaking
restaurant agreed
yes sir so you're gonna go to the
freaking grocery store
and buy food and cook food at home
much much much cheaper okay
now and so given that for two people
let's just say
i'm going to give i'm going to be a
little bit up let's say you said 800
a month for food that's high
you can make it on less but i'm giving
you a little pad
400 every two weeks okay
yes sir you'll put that in every dollar
now i had six thousand dollars coming in
and so now i have five thousand two
hundred dollars left you're with me so
far
yes sir the second thing you pay is your
all your utilities including let's get
this electric bill current
okay so it's going to take 400 because
it's 200 behind and 200 for this month
to get the electric current then you got
to pay the water if you got gas you got
to pay that
whatever your utilities are your your
cable bill if you got a big buck cable
bill you need to cut it back and get
almost nothing
just enough to have internet or
something you're broke
we're trying to get out of being broke
you're in survival mode
for a short time and you're going to
live like no one else you're going to
live on nothing beans and rice rice and
beans
so that later you never have this stress
again does that sound like a good idea
yes sir you can do this man i can tell
i've talked to people for 30 years and i
can tell when somebody's ready and this
guy's ready ken it's ready
dave can we talk about the car i'm
curious to know how much the car is
worth that has the 500
payment attached to it getting there
fast yeah yeah so
so my my car my wife's car goes
um actually i have it written down right
here give me one minute i'm sorry
it's okay but no worries uh my white car
owes nineteen thousand three hundred and
seventy dollars
and my car owes thirteen thousand two
hundred sixty
dollars what's your car actually worth
your car
to be honest with you i have no idea
what about hers
um i haven't even checked how much my
car is 500
car payment on 19 000 tells me you got a
screwed on the interest rate
because you got bad credit yeah we have
back ready and then we got the car when
i
um right after we did a a bankruptcy
like
like like almost 10 years ago and so
that car they
jacked you you're paying 15 16 interest
aren't you
yeah so i have yeah i did numbers on
monday
because i was when i read your book i
was like oh my god so we owe
84 321
and 40 000 of that is owed to the irs
okay is that on a payment plan
so i called the irs last week and then
submitted my paperwork
like two months ago and they still have
not received it so i don't even know
tell you when you get off get online at
get online at ramseysolutions.com and
click on tax
elp and find one of our tax providers to
help you get
an arrangement made for a payment plan
with the irs until you can get them paid
off but you need to get them on a
payment plan because they're going to
surprise you and come take stuff
like you're like your check yeah
they're going to come like a thief in
the night you don't want them doing that
so you got to
see what we're doing is we're getting
all of these monsters out from under the
bed and we're putting leashes on all of
them
so i think your wife's car is probably
going to be sold mainly because the
interest rate
is is just absolutely asinine
they're just killing you they're killing
you
and get you a cheap car because listen
here's the thing you make 80 000
a year you could be 100 debt-free
irs and everything in two years
i'm not talking about being current i'm
talking about debt free
in two years but you're going to have no
freaking life during that two years
and you're going to be driving a beater
and your wife's going to be driving your
old car
because it's the nicest car and the wife
gets the good car
i my wife and i we want to do whatever
it takes or
to we we're just tired we're just tired
we're tired
you're ready man you're going to do it
i'm going to show you exactly what to do
madison's going to pick up we're going
to get you signed up for financial peace
university and
all the goodies in every all the good
every dollar all the goodies in ramsey
plus
and we are here xavier i want to hear
back from you while you're fighting on
this
you've got to have more questions you
call and talk to ken and me
anytime and we will help you with this
process i'm so proud of you
you're why we're here